we're in the Far West of Ukraine
close to the border with Hungary and
Slovakia one of the greatest
concentrations of Ukraine's Roma
population lives here in the
transcarpathia region most in extreme
poverty jobs are scarce but many Roma
who moved away to cities in search of
employment are now returning to these
villages a series of anti-roma attacks
by far-right extremists has presented
these people with a stark choice work or
safety this is how it all began in April
a far-right group attacked a Roma camp
in the Ukrainian capital Kiev as this
footage is said to show it wasn't to be
the last such incident copycat attacks
have followed in late June the violence
claimed its first life 23-year old David
Pape was stabbed more than a dozen times
in the western city of l'viv his death
provoked an outcry forcing Ukraine's
politicians to break their silence and
react the teenage suspects are now in
custody but how could this have been
allowed to happen and what's happened to
the survivors
it was here in the village of baka Silvo
in transcarpathia that dahveed pop grew
up since the attacks people here have
become wary of strangers it's only
thanks to the mediation of pastor and
village elder fade there Varga that were
allowed in he takes us to meet Davi pops
widow oh boy yeah it's the first time
she spoken publicly about her husband's
murder when those teenagers came to
attack our camp they didn't say a word
they just started going at us with their
knives I begged them there are children
here but they just started attacking us
even more viciously my husband was lying
dead in front of me after that I lost
consciousness on the day of our visit a
boy I received a call from the police in
Labib asking her to testify in court she
refused out of fear our ukraine's
politicians really taking this problem
seriously we asked the deputy governor
of transcarpathia in the region's
capital doozerdom while this part of
ukraine has not seen any attack so far
it's Roma inhabitants are worried
Yaroslav goddess is devastating in his
criticism of the police in Kiev and
liveth wooly if the police had cracked
down hard on this after the first
attacks we would definitely not have
seen the murder in love if when
something like this happens it's up to
the police and politicians to come down
hard and send a message to society that
things of this kind will not be allowed
to happen
since the attacks police have responded
to requests from community leaders to
step up their patrols in Roma districts
Miroslav horvath is a Roma community
leader and local councillor very few
Roma hold elected office he uses the
position to bridge the gaps between
government and his own community many
Roma here don't even have a birth
certificate let alone a passport he's
often the only one who can help
but recently Miroslav has been
confronted with a new set of problems
as victims of the attacks come to him
for support I don't understand where
this hatred comes from we've never seen
anything like it this kind of open
discrimination these kinds of attacks we
need to get around to solving the Roma
community's problems now and not just
kick the can down the road
Miroslav takes us on a visit to Rudd
Vanka a Roma community on the edge of
Arad we meet Clara a survivor of one of
the attacks in live if they be old
people and children they smashed my
brother-in-law's head in and just left
him for dead but I don't want the
attackers to go to prison Prison doesn't
make people any better they were just
kids after all that's something we hear
time and again but it's unclear if
people are too afraid to say anything
else
then the mood turns there's been a
break-in at a local church police are
quick to suspect Roma involvement if it
was them they'll give it all back
someone broke into the church do you
have pictures we never find out how the
investigation ends for now the police
leave rod Vanka without making any
arrests these people need the police to
protect them but relations with law
enforcement are tense and marred by
suspicion so much negativity about Roma
especially online if something gets
stolen or anything bad happens people
always just rush to assume it was Roma
that's not right we urgently need the
state to protect us especially now there
are groups out there that attack Rome
and we can't be sure that some day the
violence won't reach us here in